tucked away in a valley in the Allegheny
Mountains in West Virginia is this the
Green Bank radio telescope the largest
steerable radio telescope in the world
now if you're building an optical
telescope something that looks at the
stars then you want to be on top of a
mountain you want to get to as much of
Earth's atmosphere as you can but a
radio telescope needs to be isolated
from all the radio noise that humanity
produces now one way is to build it in
the middle of a lot of mountains solid
rock does a pretty good job of shielding
but another way is to get everyone
around you to just shut up welcome to
the National Radio quiet zone this is
where I would have used a big sweeping
drum shop to get the dramatic picture
but um remote control isn't allowed II
the job of the Green Bank telescope is
actually really really flexible from
looking at objects in the solar system
to looking at objects halfway across the
universe and further it was instrumental
in uncovering the molten core of Mercury
it helped to resolve a sort of
controversy in astronomy about the
distance to a nearby star cluster and
that might sound a little bit mundane
but measuring distances in astronomy is
very hard and one of the biggest
projects the telescope does right now is
also looking for living things out there
in space it's called the breakthrough
listen project and it's a search for
extraterrestrial intelligence using the
Green Bank telescope and other
facilities like it throughout the world
the quiet zone is roughly a rectangle
about hundred miles on each side and
since 1958 the US government has put
strict limits on transmissions within
the zone partly for this telescope and
partly because of a much more secure
military facility 30 miles away that
listen to more earthly communications
some folks writing about the quiet zone
they say that all transmissions are
banned for the whole 100 miles but
that's not true there are cities within
the wider parts of the zone and the
folks there happily use Wi-Fi and cell
phones it's the quiet zone not the
silent zone out there the rules are
about big transmitters the kind that put
out TV and radio signals they're
required to use low-power directional
antennas rather than just spraying
signal everywhere within 10 miles of
here though the rules start becoming a
bit more strict this telescope is
sensitive enough that if it was pointed
the right way it could pick up a signal
with the equivalent energy of one
snowflake hitting the ground and even if
it's not pointed right at you it's got
two acres of service area to hear your
phone screaming for sale tells it just
aren't there a living in a place without
a cell phone there's definitely an
interesting change you know before two
years ago I did have a cell phone could
look up anything I wanted on Google you
know after a week of living here I
didn't even really notice it the only
difference is is that you have to plan
things ahead more if you want to meet up
with your friends you plan in advance or
you just say I'll meet up with them when
I meet up with them things like that and
many many people have come and gone
stayed for weeks or months at a time and
really none of them have ever said man I
really missed my cell phone in the
nearby town of Green Bank anything that
transmits whether that's baby monitors
or wireless doorbells is banned so is
anything that might cause interference
microwave ovens aren't allowed power
lines have we buried four feet
underground
the observatory buildings near the
telescope a huge Faraday cages keeping
all the emissions inside so this is the
anechoic chamber that I test in I first
test the device itself to see what the
emissions are then design a box for it
put it back in the chamber and see if I
did a good job or not things like
cameras for it's--that's need to see
high frequency electromagnetic energy
daily light and yet we're trying to keep
them from emitting lower frequency
electromagnetic energy usually we use a
mesh embedded in glass that's very fine
and so it doesn't distort the image too
much once you within a mile of the
telescope the restrictions are so severe
that only diesel cars are allowed
regular gasoline cars they cause too
much interference and the spark plugs
inside folks who say they're hyper
sensitive to electromagnetic fields move
to this area and even if pretty much all
the evidence says it's in their heads
they still feel better for being here
the scientists however have more
practical concerns mostly my work here
deals with radio frequency interference
our on-site and
also doing like routine runs to see if
there's anything new out there we have a
monitoring station down on site and then
we'll jump in the truck and we have
Direction finding equipment in the truck
we just basically have to look at it
with the receiver of the spectrum
analyzer and just drive around and watch
the signal peak or follow away it is
getting more difficult because because
there's more more wireless stuff out
there the wireless genie is out of the
bottle and there's so many things out
there the Internet of Things is creeping
into almost every device refrigerators
now have hot spots in them when we go
around and scan for Wi-Fi hot spots
there's there's always like three or
four printers out there the straights
just one I've heard of was an electric
pad in a dog house there was some arcing
inside the pad and was generating a lot
of RFI so my predecessor is the one that
found that one and they they fixed it by
buying the guy new heater for the dog
house thank you to everyone at the Green
Bank observatory and all the staff at
the radio telescope I am kind of
overwhelmed to be up here I am so
grateful to all of them please pull down
the description check out the links and
go see what they do
you